[Music]
the year was 2002. america was just a
few months out of 9 11. we were at war
in afghanistan and at war against an
abstract concept called
terror four confirmed cases of anthrax
all with media connections another shoe
bombing had been attempted on a u.s
passenger plane the threat of nuclear
terrorism is real whether it is a
nuclear device or a dirty bomb with the
whole country obsessed with terrorism
george bush was one of the most popular
presidents in history
but there was a problem even though huge
resources had already been expended
none of the terrorist leaders people
like osama bin laden and
muhammad had been found and americans
were looking for blood but in march of
2002 after months of waiting that
finally changed the u.s got its guy
no not osama and not khalid muhammad but
he was still really really important you
see for months the cia had been talking
about this one guy
his name was zain at abidine muhammad
hussain more commonly known as abu
zubaydah according to the cia this abu
zubaydah was one of the most fearsome
terrorists in the entire world he was
born in palestine but he had gone to
afghanistan in the 80s to fight the
soviets and after the war he stayed in
afghanistan becoming the manager of a
terrorist training camp the chief of
operations for all of al qaeda and a top
lieutenant to osama bin laden so abu
sabha was a really big fish cnn reported
that abu zubaydah might have actually
been controlling al qaeda himself based
on that information the u.s approached
the government of pakistan a country to
afghanistan's east and offered 10
million dollars if they helped find this
mysterious bad guy
so the americans did raid after raid in
pakistan looking for abu zaveda after
several attempts they finally found the
guy in a safe house
during the raid however he was shot
several times in the head suffering
severe injuries so severe the cia flew a
doctor from johns hopkins into pakistan
to keep the suspect alive
once it was clear that he would live the
cia took custody of him in america this
was announced as huge news among those
we have captured is a man named abu
zabeda
al-qaeda's chief of operations
from him
and from hundreds of others
we are learning more about how the
terrorists plan and operate
our coalition is strong
but back in pakistan the people who are
detaining him discovered something
disturbing
abu zubaydah was not exactly the guy
they thought he was you see while he was
fighting in afghanistan abu zubair was
hit in the head by some shrapnel some of
that shrapnel lodged in his brain and
gave him serious brain damage he
developed severe memory problems and
couldn't speak for a year so the man
they had arrested was not a senior al
qaeda operative he wasn't a senior
operative in anything he was a greeter
in a training camp in afghanistan but it
was not an al qaeda camp it was opposed
to al qaeda the cia had even helped set
it up in the 80s
when the government found abu zubair's
diary thousands of pages long recording
my new details of people he met or what
he ate every day they found nothing
relating to the terrorist attacks in
which he was allegedly involved
what they found instead was the story of
a mentally ill individual whose head
injury resulted in his writing the diary
in any one of three different
personalities the fbi senior expert on
al qaeda said himself this guy is insane
certifiable split personality
the diaries showed that abu zubaydah
simply wasn't involved in al qaeda he
wrote more about his deep attachment to
his mother than about any involvement in
terrorist activities
here's one diary entry
now i don't cry when i remember my dad
beating up my mom
i don't cry when i remember her crying
like a child in my arms when i was a
child
i don't cry when i remember all these
things as much as i cry when i remember
that i offended her
this was not exactly the master
terrorist the u.s thought they had
captured but the u.s government had
already said very publicly that this guy
was a top operative in al qaeda and a
trusted confidant of osama bin laden
among those we have captured is a man
named abu zabeda
al-qaeda's chief of operations
so in april 2002 president bush turned
to his cia director and told him
i said he was important you're not going
to let me lose face on this are you the
cia director responded that no he
wouldn't let the president lose face so
what was initially a mistake was
declared to be true and became a
fabrication
abu zubaydah became the first high-value
detainee of the war on terror two weeks
after his capture he was transported to
a black site in thailand where he could
be subject to a new method of
interrogation the cia was testing out
almost immediately after abu zubaida was
captured the cia began discussing how to
interpret the us's prohibition on
torture in order to allow for what they
called enhanced interrogation
and at the black site
they put that plan into effect here's
how a government report described the
atmosphere of the prison
the cable described abu zubaida's cell
as white with no natural lighting or
windows but with four halogen lights
pointed into the cell
security officers wore all black
uniforms including boots gloves
balaclavas and goggles to keep abu
zubaydah from identifying the officers
as well as to prevent abu subaida from
seeing the security guards as
individuals who he may attempt to
establish a relationship or dialogue
with
the security officers communicated by
hand signals when they were with abu's
beta and used handcuffs and leg shackles
to maintain control
in addition either loud rock music was
played or noise generators were used to
enhance abu zubaydah's sense of
hopelessness
abu zubaido was typically kept naked and
sleep deprived
during his time in thailand abu zubaydah
was kept in terrible conditions at the
beginning he was given no solid food and
kept naked and shackled to a chair
after a few weeks he was given rice once
a day and allowed to sleep naked on the
floor
abu sabha was kept totally isolated for
an entire month while the cia developed
a plan for more aggressive torture
in late july they began testing a
procedure called waterboarding in which
a prisoner would be strapped to a table
with water poured over their head in
order to simulate the experience of
drowning in august 2002 alone abu
zubaydah was waterboarded 83 times
for 17 straight days the cia used a
variety of techniques waterboarding
slamming him against a concrete wall
confining him in a small box depriving
him of sleep blasting white noise and
keeping him in a freezing room as the
torture continued abu zubair became so
broken and compliant that when an
interrogator snapped his finger twice
abuzabado would lie down flat to be
waterboarded in at least one session he
became completely unresponsive totally
desensitized to the torture
all of this was filmed by the cia and 92
tapes were produced to what was done in
thailand but while they were torturing
abu zubaydah the cia began to find that
he wasn't really able to provide them
much information
the cia still thought he was holding
back so they continued torturing him
in order to prevent further torture abu
zubaydah told them what they wanted to
hear
he told them that al qaeda wanted to
attack the brooklyn bridge and the
statue of liberty and that they knew how
to build a nuclear weapon and smuggle it
into america he even told them that
al-qaeda had ties to saddam hussein's
government in iraq
all of these false statements were used
by the bush administration to justify
expanding the war on terror
obliterated statements were a big part
of the intelligence that america cited
in invading iraq the next year
but what abu zubaida was telling his
torturers was never actually useful
according to the washington post not a
single significant plot was foiled as a
result of abu zubaida's tortured
confessions
soon the cia began to have doubts about
the information of zubaida was providing
and about their methods in getting that
information some of them even requested
that if abuzabeta died during
interrogation his body be cremated so
that the torture wouldn't be discovered
so in 2005 a cia agent named gina haspel
the person who oversaw the black site in
thailand ordered the destruction of 90
videotapes of abu zubaida's torture
in september 2006 abu zubaydah left cia
custody and was transferred to
guantanamo bay america's main detention
camp for enemy combatants by then the
cia had already concluded that abu
zubaydah was in fact
not even a member of al-qaeda
by the time that abuza arrived in
guantanamo the torture had fully broken
him and that was more than a decade ago
to this day abu zubaydah is still in
captivity in guantanamo the country that
tortured him having simply forgotten
about him it never mattered that they
knew he was innocent just look at what
happened to the people who tortured him
was the beta gina haspel who oversaw was
the beta's torture became director of
the cia in 2018. thank you again for
giving me the opportunity to serve and
to carry out the critical work of
helping protect our country our people
and our way of life thank you very much
president bush retired to his ranch in
texas please welcome president george w
bush
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
meanwhile is still in guantanamo bay he
has never been charged with anything
more than 10 years after the government
concluded he wasn't a terrorist he's
still held in strict detention
my mother he said in one letter to the
outside world i have not seen her in so
long
i'm a smile good feet for the gravel
institute
[Music]
you